[Musique]
14 juillet sur les Champs-Élysées au
milieu de plus de 100000 Parisiens le
général de Gaulle accompagné du Premier
ministre monsieur Pompidou et de
Monsieur Messmer ministre des armées est
venu présider le défilé traditionnel
[Musique]
il est pour lui avait un sens précis ce
défilé c'était l'armée d'une France
dégagée des luttes coloniales
derrière les grandes écoles
c'était une armée transformée
[Musique]
reformée à la mesure de l'époque
avec les unités d'élite et les
parachutistes le célèbre premier
régiment de la Légion étrangère qui
s'illustre depuis plus d'un siècle sur
tous les continents avait repris sa
place cette année dans le défilé
mais le sommet de la manifestation
c'était l'apparition pour la première
fois d'une brigade blindée élément
majeurs des forces d'intervention
moderne
par les chars à MX de 30 tonnes qui
armeront progressivement les unités de
cet ordre capable d'opérer dans une
atmosphère nucléaire suivi de chasseurs
de chars à missiles cette formation
nouvelle composée de 300 engins cheniers
de 4000 hommes né qu'un début
en effet le programme de 1959 prévoit la
formation de 6 divisions de choc de
18000 hommes chacune c'est cette armée
nouvelle et pour ainsi dire régénérer
que la foule parisienne a salué en ce 14
juillet l'armée de demain qui devient
l'armée d'aujourd'hui
rarement visite royale leur a causé au
temps de soucis au gouvernement
britannique que celle du roi Paul
degraisse et de la reine Frédérica à
Londres rarement aussi autant de
policiers auront été mobilisés pour
faire respecter la belle ordonnance du
cortège traditionnel cher au cœur des
Londoniens
devant ce déploiement cependant les
manifestants n'ont pas renoncé à
profiter du séjour des souverains grecs
pour réclamer la libération des
prisonniers incarcérées en Grèce depuis
la guerre civile
employant systématiquement la technique
éprouvée qui consiste à s'asseoir et à
rester immobile sur la chaussée ils se
sont heurtés à la police londonienne qui
elle aussi et parfaitement et à cette
technique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Bruxelles à sans doute pris son aire de
vacances et cependant tous les touristes
qui débarquent sur la magnifique
Grand-Place peuvent comprendre qu'un
graphe problème est posé à la nation
belle celui qui affiche innocemment les
écriteaux bilingues celui des deux
langues et des deux races flamants et
Wallons le gouvernement avait pensé
faire absorber par la capitale si
commune or la banlieue est flamande d'où
le drame l'opinion flamande exprimons-la
par la voix de Monsieur De Coninck
député de Bruxelles
nous préconisons un statut organique
pour les deux communautés nous nous
opposons avec la plus extrême énergie
contre tout empiètement du territoire
sur le territoire flamand à partir de la
francisation partant de Bruxelles
le fédéralisme est déjà dans la dans les
fêtes et permettra dans l'avenir de
préserver la culture flamande qui a
toujours été tenu sous l'étouffar
l'opinion wallonne le président du
Mouvement populaire wallon Monsieur Léon
Defossé nous l'expose
pour nous allons l'essentiel des
critiques que nous dirigeons contre les
projets linguistiques du gouvernement
c'est qu'ils traduisent une volonté
délibérée de flamandisation systématique
et intégrale de l'administration et même
de Bruxelles en général devant une telle
offensive flamingante systématique la
seule réaction de la Wallonie c'est de
réclamer d'exiger sur l'autonomie
politique dans le cadre d'un État
fédéral il est certain en effet à notre
sens que le fédéralisme et la seule
chance la dernière chance de survie d'un
état belge
grave question comme on le voit et qui
depuis quelques années a sensibilisé les
foules des deux côtés faut-il rappeler
ces marches flamandes sur Bruxelles et
ses manifestations qui se terminaient
voici encore quelques mois dans la
violence
la violence n'a pas des armées au coeur
même des discussions actuelles qui tout
de même aboutissaient à une sorte
d'accord une bombe détériorer la colonne
du Congrès symbole de la Charte de la
Belgique indépendante
[Musique]
et quand disent les Bruxellois
je fais pleure tout ce qui s'est passé
ici en Belgique pour le moment d'autant
plus que l'unité du pays est en jeu je
trouve que les Français les c'est-à-dire
les Belges l'expression française et les
Belges expressions flamand doit pouvoir
s'entendre il n'y a pas de raison nous
sommes tous belges au fond et bien
monsieur moi vous savez moi je suis
contre je suis un peu contre tout dans
le fond mais je trouve que le Belge ça
est un Belge le Belge c'est un belge par
conséquent c'est anormal zéro bientôt
une barrière une barrière à Lost le
coupant et là on vous demandera votre
carte d'identité on a dit dans le temps
ce qu'il donne brinden savoir si on
savait le dire en flamand et à ce
moment-là si vous saviez pas le dire on
vous coupez la gorge et bien moi je suis
pas d'accord et c'est parce que moi je
veux aller à la côte à la mer la mer ça
appartient à tout le monde les Ardennes
c'est bien mais moi j'aime pas les
Ardennes de toute façon nous sommes des
Belges qu'on soit wallon qu'on soit
bruxellois ou qu'on soit flamand c'est
la même chose somme de belles soucieux
c'est tout un seul Belge contemple cette
affrontement avec sérénité le
Manneken-Pis mais il n'en pense pas
moins
de tous les champions se sont bien les
nageurs qui ont choisi le sport le plus
agréable surtout pendant la canicule et
là au Grand Prix de Paris malgré la
chaleur les sprinteurs s'en donnent à
cœur joie dans le 129 livres Alain
godwallez une fois de plus est encore le
meilleur 55 secondes c'est loin du
record du monde mais qui c'est
irlandebout si la petite Christine Caron
continue de nager comme elle le fait
depuis le début de la saison
passage qui a
à peine si on d'une super
chance celui du 100 mètres d'eau en une
minute 9 secondes 6/10 et celui du 200
mètres d'eau en deux minutes 33 secondes
5 dixièmes
[Applaudissements]
enfin prodige
[Musique]
les saint Bernard en témoignent alors
manières avec une certaine turbulence
d'ailleurs
c'était dans les Alpes
[Musique]
que les Pyrénées n'avaient été qu'un
hors-d'oeuvre une promenade en quelque
sorte sauf pour le beige vin Lloyd pris
à froid dans la montagne en revanche les
Alpes n'ont pardonné aucune défaillance
et Dieu sait s'il y en a eu
la plus dramatique celle de l'un des
favoris Raymond Poulidor on attendait un
trio sans Poulidor août la bataille des
Alpes s'est résumé en induel Antilles
bah à Montech va monter ce numéro 41 le
roi de la montagne est encore maillot
jaune avant l'arrivée à Chamonix et
Jacques Anquetil qui est vraiment le
Super-Man de ce tour 1963 fait à cette
occasion la preuve de ses immenses
qualités
gagne la grande étape des Alpes à
Chamonix c'est là qu'il a remporté le
Tour de France cette année il n'a pas eu
besoin de l'étape contre l'âme
la suite n'est plus qu'une formalité et
lorsque le peloton est en vue de la
capitale française quelques jours plus
tard ce sont des centaines de milliers
de Parisiens qui ovacionnent Jacques
anquil vainqueur pour la quatrième fois
du Tour de France
méritait quand même une récompense
pour Jacques Antilles c'est le record
des victoires jamais personne avant lui
même Louison Bobet n'avait fait mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]